au président christian cambon pour le
groupe l'est républicain monsieur le
président c'est le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des affaires
étrangères depuis des mois la turquie de
monsieur r 2 one multiplie les
provocations à l'égard de ses alliés
occidentaux chantage aux flux
migratoires achats d'armes russes pour
fragiliser le temps forages gaziers
illégaux dans les eaux grec et chypriote
offensive contre nos alliés kurde en
syrie ingérence en libye
pis encore de manière irresponsable
au lieu d'agir en faveur de la paix la
turquie attise le terrible conflit du
haut karabagh en envoyant des avions des
drones suicide et des mercenaires pour
soutenir l'offensive de l'azerbaïdjan
contre l'arménie
ceci n'est pas encore suffisant alors
que la france vient de traverser un
drame épouvantable
le président turc offense par ses propos
le président de la république insultant
par là même notre pays tout entier
comble de l'inacceptable
cet amalgame inadmissible avec la
situation des juifs dans les années 30
qui donne la nausée
alors monsieur le ministre va-t-on
encore une fois de plus c'est sans
réagir
supporter longtemps d'être le bouc
émissaire de la crise économique et
politique qui secoue la turquie si la
turquie nous trouve aussi infréquentable
va-t-on par exemple continuer à prêter
chaque année 300 millions d'euros 3
milliards depuis dix ans à ce pays et
cette année l'afd qui s'apprête à monter
à porter ce montant à 400 millions
connaissez vous monsieur le ministre un
banquier qui vous prêtent de l'argent
pour se faire copieusement insulté alors
me dit-on oui la france a aussi des
intérêts comme ses voisins des intérêts
économiques en turquie je ne le mets
connais pas mais l'appel au boycott des
produits français déjà une réponse et
devrait nous inciter à beaucoup plus de
lui
si dit et pour l'avenir de nos
entreprises dans ce pays alors ma
question est bien simple quelles mesures
allez vous prendre ici en france et
aussi au conseil européen de décembre où
nos amis sont un petit peu mou on va
dire sur leur soutien pour sanctionner
le dirigeant nationaliste qui veut jouer
à l'empereur ottoman alors qu'il fait
offense à son peuple et aussi à
l'histoire même de la turquie merci la
parole et au secrétaire d'état chargé
des affaires européennes
monsieur clément bonne monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président quand
bon permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
prier de bien vouloir excuser l'absence
de jean yves le drian le mist de
l'europe des affaires étrangères qui est
retenu par un deuil familial
je rejoins en tout point ce que vous
dites sur la turquie le dernier épisode
qui repousse chaque jour les frontières
de l'inacceptable du président erdogan
qui a insulté le prénom de la république
merci pour cette unité dans le soutien
est révélateur non pas d'un moment de
tension passagers mais d'une stratégie
d'ensemble que vous avez décrite qui est
celle de la turquie de multiplier les
provocations tous azimuts c'est toujours
le même objectif exercer une pression
maximale sur ses voisins et
singulièrement bien sûr sur l'union
européenne
nous avons trop longtemps été naïf et je
crois que puisque vous rappeler les
propos qui ont été tenus à l'égard dû
prendre la république c'est l'honneur de
la france et c'est l'honneur dû prendre
la république d'avoir tout au long des
derniers mois en particulier
essayez de dessiller l'europe l'union
européenne sur ce qu'est la réalité du
régime turc actuel ce qu'est la réalité
de la politique étrangère turque car
c'est la même stratégie du haut karabakh
à la libye en passant par l'ami terres
orientales et les insultes dont vous
faisiez est temps je crois que nous
avons était le fer de lance de cette
prise de conscience européenne qui vous
avez raison n'est pas encore suffisante
mais les mots de solidarité qui ont été
exprimées ces derniers jours par
l'ensemble des dirigeants européens sans
ambiguïté sont aussi un fait nouveau qui
marque le que le consensus évolué vers
une position de fermeté qui a défendu la
france
nous allons aller plus loin et vous avez
raison nous continuerons cette stratégie
de réactions françaises et européennes
cela peut passer par de nouvelles
sanctions je rappelle que la france en
avait été à l'initiative
l'an dernier après des forages déjà dans
les eaux chypriotes nous avons un
rendez-vous au conseil européen de
décembre et nous pousserons évidemment
en faveur de mesures européennes de
réaction forte dont l'outil possible des
sanctions il faut être précis aussi ça
ne doit pas être le résumé de notre
politique étrangère y compris à l'égard
de la turquie et le prix dans la
république n'a pas hésité non plus à
avoir des mesures de réaction par une
présence militaire renforcée par exemple
en méditerranée orientale
cet été un point précis sur la question
que vous soulevez des financements
français et européens l' agence
française de développement est active
depuis 2004 en turquie elle doit elle
est en train de le faire revoir sa
politique d'intervention d'évidence en
turquie je tiens à signaler pour qu'il
n'y ait aucune ambiguïté que d'ores et
déjà il n'y a pas de subvention versée
la turquie il ya semble de prêt qui ne
transite pas par l'état turc et qui
soutiennent un certain nombre d'actions
de la société civile mais nous reverrons
aussi cette politique européenne et
française de prêt à la turquie parmi
d'autres instruments de réponse dans la
prochain dans les prochains mois merci
en tout cas de votre soutien à monsieur
pris la parole et sa collègue étienne
poumirol
[Applaudissements]